let's get to the fun part let's talk
about string theory
yes uh let's uh
discuss some technical basics of uh
string theory what is string theory
what is the string how many dimensions
are we talking about
what are the different states how do we
represent the elementary particles
and the laws of physics using this
new framework so string theory
is the idea that the fundamental
entities are not particles
but extended higher dimensional objects
like one-dimensional strings
like loops these loops could be open
like uh
with two ends like an interval or a
circle
without any ends so and they're
vibrating and moving around in space
so how big they are well you can of
course stretch it and make it big
or you can just let it be whatever it
wants it can be as small as a point
because the
circle can shrink to a point and be very
light
or you can you know stretch it and
becomes very massive or it could
oscillate and become massive that way so
depends on
which kind of state you have in fact the
string can have infinitely many modes
depending on which kind of oscillation
it's doing like a guitar has different
harmonics string has different harmonics
but
for the string each harmonic is a
particle so each particle will give you
ah this is a more massive harmonic
this is a less mass so the lightest
harmonic so to speak is no harmonics
which means like
the string strung to a point and then it
becomes like a
massless particles or light particles
like photon
and graviton and so forth so when when
you look at
tiny strings which are strung to a point
the lightest ones
they look like the particles that we we
think they're like particles in other
words
from far away they look like a point but
of course if you zoom in there's this
tiny little you know little circle
that's there
that's strong to almost a point should
we be imagining
this is to the visual intuition should
we be imagining literally strings that
are
potentially connected as a loop or not
when you and when somebody outside of
physics
is imagining a basic element of string
theory which is a string
should we literally be thinking about a
string yes you should literally think
about string
but string with zero thickness with zero
thickness
so notice it's a it's a it's a loop of
energy so to speak
if you can think of it that way and so
there's a tension like the regular
string if you pull it there's you know
you have to you have to stretch it
but it's not like a thickness like
you're made of something it's just
energy
it's not made of atoms or something like
that but and it is very
very tiny very tight much smaller than
uh
elementary particles of physics much
smaller so we think if you let the
string to be
by itself the lower state they'll be
like fuzziness or the size of that tiny
little circle which is like a point
about could be anything between we don't
know exact size but
in different models have different sizes
but something of the order of 10 to the
minus
let's say 30 centimeters so
10 to the minus 30 centimeters just to
compare with the size of the atom which
is 10 to the minus eight centimeters
is 22 orders of magnitude smaller
so so unimaginably small very small so
we basically think from far away string
is like a point particle
and that's why a lot of the things that
we learned about point particle physics
carries over
directly to strings so therefore there's
not not much of a mystery why
particle physics was successful because
string is like a particle when it's not
stretched
but it turns out having this size being
able to oscillate
get bigger turned out to be resolving
these puzzles that feynman was having in
calculating
his diagrams and it gets rid of those
infinities
so when you're trying to do those
infinities the regions that give
infinities to feynman as soon as you get
to those regions then this
string starts to oscillate and these
oscillation structure of the strings
resolves those infinities to finite
answer at the end so
the size of the string the fact is one
dimensional gives a finite answer at the
end
resolves this paradox now
perhaps it's also useful to recount of
how string theory came to be
yes because it wasn't like somebody said
well let me
solve the problem of einstein's solve
the problem that simon had with
unifying einstein's theory with quantum
mechanics by replacing the point by a
string no
that's not the way the thought process
the thought process was
much more random physicist
veneziano in this case was trying to
describe the interactions they were
seeing in
colliders in accelerators
and they were seeing that some process
in some process when two particles came
together
and joined together and went they were
separately
in one way and the opposite way they
behaved the same way
in some way there was a symmetry a
duality
which she didn't understand the
particles didn't seem to have that
symmetry
he said i don't know what it is what's
the reason that these colliders and
experiments we're doing seems to have
the symmetry but let me write a
mathematical formula
which exhibits that symmetry he used
gamma functions beta functions and all
that you know complete math
no physics other than trying to get
symmetry out of his equation
he just wrote down a formula as the
answer for a process
not not a method to compute it just say
wouldn't it be nice if this was the
answer
yes this is looked at this one that's
intriguing it has the symmetry all right
but what is this
where's this coming from which which
kind of physics gives you this
so i don't know yeah a few years later
people saw that oh the equation that
you're right is the process you're
writing
in the intermediate channels that
particles come together
seems to have all the harmonics
harmonics sounds like a string
let me see if what you're describing has
anything with the strength and people
try to see if what he's doing has
anything with strings
oh yeah indeed if i study scattering of
two strings i get exactly the formula
you wrote down
that was the reinterpretation of what he
had written in the formula
as a string but still had nothing to do
with gravity
it had nothing to do with resolving the
problems of gravity with quantum
mechanics
it was just trying to explain a process
that people were seeing in hydronic
physics collisions
so it took a few a few more years to get
to that point
they did notice that uh physics notice
that
whenever you try to find the spectrum of
strings you always get a massive
particle
which has exactly the properties that
the graviton is supposed to have and no
particle in hydronic physics that had
that property
you are getting a massless graviton as
part of this scattering without
looking for it it was forced on you
people were not trying to solve quantum
gravity quantum gravity was pushed on
them
i don't want this graviton get rid of it
they couldn't get rid of it
they gave up trying to get rid of it
physicists said shuriken short said you
know what
strength is theory of quantum gravity
they change their perspective altogether
we are not describing the hydronic
physics we are describing this theory of
quantum graph
and that's when string theory probably
got uh like uh
exciting that this could be the unifying
theory exactly it got exciting but at
the same time not so fast namely
it should have been fast but it wasn't
because particle physics through quantum
filter were so successful
at that time this is mid-70s standard
model of physics electromagnetism and
unification of electromagnetic forces
with all the other forces
were beginning to take place without the
gravity part
everything was working beautifully for
particle physics
and so that was the shining golden age
of quantum field theory and all the
experiments standard model this and that
unification it's spontaneous symmetry
breaking was taking place all of them
was nice
this was kind of like a slideshow and
nobody was paying so much attention
this exotic string is needed for quantum
gravity ah maybe there's other ways
maybe we should do something else
so anyhow it wasn't paid much attention
to and this took a little bit more
effort to try to actually connect it to
to the
reality there were a few more steps
first of all there was a puzzle
that you were getting extra dimensions
string was not
working well with three spatial
dimensions on one time it needed extra
dimension
now there are different versions of
strings but the version that ended up
being related to having
particles like electron what we call
fermions needed 10 dimensions what we
call
superstring now why super white the word
super it turns out
this this version of the string which
had fermions
had an extra symmetry which we call
supersymmetry
this is a symmetry between a particle
and another particle
with exactly the same properties same
mass same charge etc
the only difference is that one of them
has a little different spin than the
other one
and one and one of them is a boson one
of them is a fermion because of that
shift of spin otherwise they are
identical so there was this symmetry
string theory had this symmetry in fact
supersymmetry was discovered
through string theory theoretically
so theoretically the first place that
this was observed when when you were
describing these
fermionic strings so that was the
beginning of the study of supersymmetry
was the via string theory
and then it had remarkable properties
that you know this symmetry
meant and so forth that people began
studying supersymmetry after that
and that was continuation that was the
kind of a tangent direction at the
beginning
for string theory but people in particle
physics started also thinking oh
supersymmetry is great let's see if we
can have
supersymmetry in particle physics and so
forth forget about strings and they
developed on a different track as well
supersymmetry in different models
became a subject on its own right
understanding supersymmetry and what
does this mean
because it unified boson fermi it
unifies some ideas together
so photon is a boson electron is a
fermion
could things like that be somehow
related it was a kind of a natural kind
of a question to try to kind of unify
because
in physics we love unification now
gradually string theory was beginning to
show signs of unification it had
graviton
but people found that you also have
things like photons in them
different excitations of string behave
like photons another one behaves like
electron
so a single string was unifying all
these particles into one object
that's remarkable it's in 10 dimensions
though
it is not our universe because we live
in three plus one dimension how could
that be possibly true
so this was a conundrum it was elegant
it was beautiful but it was very
specific
about which dimension you're getting
which structure you're getting
it wasn't saying oh you just put d
equals to four you'll get your space
time dimension that you want no
it didn't like that it said i want 10
dimensions and that's the way it is
so it was very specific now so people
try to reconcile this by the idea that
you know
maybe these extra dimensions are tiny so
if you take
three macroscopic spatial dimensions on
one time
and six extra tiny spatial dimensions
like tiny spheres or tiny circles
then it avoids contradiction with
manifest fact that we haven't seen extra
dimensions in experiments today
so that was a way to avoid conflict
now this was a way to avoid conflict but
it was not observed in experiments
string observed in experiments no
because it's so small
so it's beginning to sound a little bit
funny
similar feeling to the way perhaps drag
had felt
about this positron plus or minus you
know it was beginning to sound a little
bit like
oh yeah not only i have to have 10
dimension but i also have to this i have
to also listen
and so you so conservative physicists
would say um
you know i haven't seen these
experiments i don't know if they are
really there are you pulling my leg
i do want me to imagine things that are
not there
so this was an attitude of some
physicist towards string theory despite
the fact
that the puzzle of gravity and quantum
mechanics merging together work
but still was this skepticism you're
putting all these things that you want
me to imagine
there are these extra dimensions that i
cannot see uh-huh and you want me to
believe that stream that you have not
even seen experiments are real aha okay
what else do you want me to believe
so it was kind of beginning to sound a
little funny now
i was i would pass for forward a little
bit further
a few decades later when string3 became
the mainstream of efforts to unify the
forces and particles together
we learned that these extra dimensions
actually solve problems
if they weren't in nuisance the way they
originally appeared
first of all the properties of these
extra dimensions
reflected the number of particles we got
in four dimensions
if you took these six dimensions to have
like six five holes or four holes it
tends to
change the number of particles that you
see in four dimensional space time
you get one electron and one muon if you
had this but if you did the other j
shape
you get something else so geometrically
you could get different kinds of physics
so it was kind of in
a mirroring of geometry by physics down
in the macroscopic space so these extra
dimensions
were becoming useful fine but we didn't
need the extra dimensions to just write
an electron in three dimensions we did
we dropped it so
so what was there any other puzzle yes
there were
hawking hawking had been studying black
holes in mid 70s
following the work of wickenstein what
predicted
that black holes have entropy
so beckenstein had tried to attach the
entropy to the black hole
if you throw something into that black
hole the entropy seems to go down
because you have something entropy in
outside the black hole and you throw it
entropy was you it black
was unique so the entropy did not have
any black light no entropy
so you seem the entropy seem to go down
and so that's against the laws of
thermodynamics so
beckenstein was trying to say no no
therefore black hole must have an
entropy so he was trying to understand
that he found that if you assign
entropy to the to be proportional to the
area of the black hole
it seems to work and then hawking found
not only that's correct
he found the correct proportionality
factor factor over one quarter of the
area and planck units is the
correct amount of entropy and he gave an
argument using
quantum semi-classical arguments which
barely which means basically using a
little bit of quantum mechanics
because he didn't have the full quantum
mechanics of string there he could do
some
aspects of approximate quantum arguments
so heuristic quantum arguments
led to this entropy form formula but
then
he didn't answer the following question
he was getting
a big entropy for the black hole the
black hole with the size of the horizon
of a black hole is huge has a huge
amount of entropy
what are the microstates of this entropy
when you say for example the gaseous
entropy
you count where the atoms are you count
this this bucket or that but there's an
information about there and so on you
can't them
for the black hole the way hawking was
thinking there was no degree of freedom
you throw them in
and there was just one solution so where
are these
entropy what are what are these
microscopic states
they were hidden somewhere so later in
string theory
the work that we did with my colleagues
strong manager
in particular showed that these
ingredients in string theory
of black hole arise from the extra
dimensions
so the degrees of freedom are are hidden
in terms of things like strings
wrapping these extra circles in these
hidden dimensions
and then we started counting how many
ways like the strings can wrap around
this circle and the
extra dimension of that circle and
counted the microscopic degrees of
freedom
and lo and behold we got the microscopic
degrees of freedom that
hawking was predicting four dimensions
so the extra dimensions became useful
for resolving a puzzle in four
dimensions the puzzle was
where are the degrees of freedom of the
black hole hidden the answer
hidden in the extra dimensions the tiny
extra dimensions
so then by this time it was beginning to
we see aspects
that extra dimensions are useful for
many things it's not a nuisance
it wasn't to be kind of you know be
ashamed of it was actually in the
welcome features
new feature nevertheless
you